[موسيقى]
يوميا بعشرات الصيادين الذين يتعافتون
لممارسه هوايتهم القديمه في صيد الاسماك
منهم طبعا من يمارس الصيد كمنه ومصدر
للرزق فصيدوا احد اقدم المهن في تركيا
واعرقها
بيروت بين قساوه العيش
[موسيقى]
والكلاب بالنسبه لمريم
يوجد صيادون لكن لا وجود للاسماك في
الانهار الارض التي تغنت بالسمك وصيده
وذكرته في امثالها الشعبيه اليوم مهدده
بالانقراض مهنه الصيف بسبب ازمه صحه
المياه المستمره منذ عامين الى الان عرفت
تونس منذ القدم السيد البحريه الذي يمارسه
جانب من سكانها النشيطين على طول سواحلها
الممتده على قرابه 1500 كيلو متر في حوض
البحر الابيض المتوسط اكتسبت بذلك
[موسيقى]
رغم ان اسطنبول مدينه محاطه بالبحار ورغم
ان مهنه صيد السمك عريقه في هذه المدينه
منذ العهد البيزنطي لكنه مؤرخون قالوا ان
الثقافه اكل السمك بشكل الشائع حاليا لم
تكن لدى الاتراك في القرون الماضيه
[موسيقى]
وفقا مؤرخي فان اطباق السمك المتنوعه كانت
حكرا على طبقه النبلاء في الدوله
العثمانيه بينما كانت الاقليات
كاليونانيين والارمن واليهود اكثر ميلا
لتناول السمك من الاتراك
[موسيقى]
هوايه ليست حكرا على الفقراء بل الاثرياء
ايضا خصوصا في عطله نهايه الاسبوع
[موسيقى]
ليه مات مريم في البحر ادواتها وترسبات
زواجين الفاشلين
الاحوال
[موسيقى]
صدرها من لون عينيها
مريم منذ قرابه العقدين
[موسيقى]
اختفى سمك
يا صياد
الشمال
صدقني بنيه
قلبي بشير
بشده
كانت كل المواسم متاحه لصيد السمك
باستثناء مده تحدد من منتصف شباط الى
منتصف ايار اما اليوم فكل المواسم صارت
صحيحه بسبب انخفاض منسوب المياه بالامر
[تصفيق]
جواري للمياه وانتشار ظاهره الصيد الجائر
فضلا عن غياب الرعايه الحكوميه لمهنه
الصيد والصيادين تسبب بهجره 20% من مستثمر
البحيرات السمكيه
[موسيقى]
هنا في حلقه الولد التونسيه اوسقليه
الصغيره مدينه الاسماك والبحر والتي يوجد
بها اكبر ميناء البحرين في تونس
تغنى بسحر شواطئها الفنان فريد الاطرش صيد
السمك وهو احد ابرز المهني واقدمه
ينتشروا صيدوه في الميناء والبحر ليظفر
باجود انواعه ومن المياه مباشره
[موسيقى]
اطول شارعا بمحله تقديم السمك في تونس
العاصمه بصغر الصيادله هنا وهم جزء من
هويه المدينه وروانقها يتشبثون بعشقهم رغم
قله الانتاج الذي يحدث قلتهم لاسباب عده
من بينها العوامل الطبيعيه والصيد
العشوائيه
[موسيقى]